hallo freunde der sonne ich bin es
wieder mal eure chemikerin des
vertrauens nur manche fragen sich nur zu
recht wieso darf die sich chemikerin des
vertrauens nennen wenn sie über drogen
spricht also erstmal fast nie aber fair
enough ändern wir das herzlich
willkommen zu unserem neuen format
drohung wissenschaftlich geprüft
heute cannabis ihr könnt auch schon mal
hier oben abstimmen über welche droge
wir unser nächstes drogen
wissenschaftlich geprüft machen soll
heute sprechen wir über alles was man
über cannabis wissen sollte nach
aktuellem stand der forschung also holt
durch einen legalen tee macht es euch
gemütlich los geht's cannabis oder hand
hat ja tradition seit mindestens 5000
jahren pfeifen sich menschen das zeug
reinen entweder als medizin oder einfach
zum spaß doch wie viele drogen viel
cannabis irgendwann in ungnade als
teufelszeug das bekämpft werden muss
also wer von euch hier so alt wie ich
und erinnert sich noch an die keine
macht den drogen kampagne in den 90ern
und bin ich die einzige die das damals
grammatikalisch überhaupt nicht
verstanden hat das nicht heißen kein er
macht die trophy war es jedenfalls noch
das kiffen damals etwas so unfassbar
schlimmes ich ein kind war hat man über
kiffende jugendliche gesprochen als
hätten die ihre seele satan
höchstpersönlich gekauft also nach dem
motto heute ein joint morgen
straßenstrich übermorgen tod durch
heroin überdosis heute bewegen sich
viele länder auf eine legalisierung von
cannabis zu auch in deutschland gibt es
druck für eine legalisierung mit zwei
hauptargumenten erster cannabis ist doch
harmlos vergleicht das mal mit alkohol
und zweitens cannabis ist medizinisch so
wertvoll das darf man nicht einschränkt
schauen wir mal ob das wirklich stimmt
cannabis die rätselhafte droge man
wusste zwar schon lange dass cannabis
hey macht aber nicht warum
1964 wurde der hauptverantwortliche
inhaltsstoff entdeckt
tetrahydrocannabinol kurz thc das
übrigens in unserem letzten video sehr
oft als lieblings molekül genannt wurde
der name cannabinoid kommt also schlicht
und einfach daher dass man das molekül
in der cannabispflanze gefunden hat
genauso wie das chemische element
darmstadtium so heiß war es in darmstadt
gefunden bzw erzeugt wurde
jedenfalls was thc im körper genau macht
blieb lange eine reetz
denn in seiner chemischen struktur
unterscheidet sich thc von vielen
anderen pflanzlichen drogen oder gift
die gehören meistens zu den alkaloiden
von morphin über nikotin bis koffein
oder auch people ihnen das ist die
scharfe substanz im pfeffer alles
alkaloide erkennbar am stück stoff also
dass es das gibt es beim thc nicht doch
erstmal einmal die struktur von thc
entdeckt hatte fand man lauter weitere
substanzen cannabis die so ähnlich
aussah also in dieselbe chemische klasse
gehören diese klasse nannte ban
cannabinoide in cannabis sind bisher
über 100 verschiedene cannabinoide
entdeckt worden
1 1 war besonders seltsam nämlich man
kannte im körper überhaupt kein rezept
tor der durch so eine chemische struktur
aktiviert werden könnte damit die
substanz überhaupt als droge wirken kann
1990 fand man die lösung des rätsels im
gehirn von ratten
dort entdeckte man einen rezeptor der
von thc aktiviert wird und das
bestätigte sie stellt das auch andere
tiere einschließlich dass menschen auch
diese rezeptoren nur warum haben wir
diesen rezeptor für cannabis hat hey
werden irgendein evolutionären vorteil
es dauerte zwei weitere jahre bis man
herausfand wozu dieser thc rezeptor
eigentlich dabei also man fand die
dazugehörigen körpereigenen substanzen
die man schlichtweg endocannabinoide
nannte was so viel heißt wie innere
cannabinoide an hat also dieses
endocannabinoide nur entdeckt weil man
herausfinden wollte warum cannabis
heimmacht nun wohl gemerkt hatte der
mensch natürlich schon ein
endocannabinoide system lange bevor er
zum ersten mal eine hanfpflanze erblickt
hat an pflanze ist voll schwierige wort
wie funktioniert also dass
endocannabinoide system
es gibt hauptsächlich zwei cannabinoid
rezeptoren den cannabinoid rezeptoren 1
kurz c b1 der sitzt hauptsächlich in
gehirn und rückenmark und den
cannabinoid rezeptoren 2 tb 2 den findet
man hauptsächlich in den zellen des
immunsystems bei der rezeptoren kommen
aber auch in vielen anderen geweben im
körper vor dh
endocannabinoide system spielt an vielen
verschiedenen stellen im körper eine
rolle und unsere endocannabinoide haben
auch sehr vielfältige funktionen zum
beispiel gehirnzellen kommunizieren
miteinander durch das hin- und
herschicken von molekülen und
endocannabinoide gehören auch zu diesen
kommunikations molekülen in zum beispiel
eine hirn zelle von der anderen einen
übertriebenen input bekommt kann sie mit
hilfe von endocannabinoide diese
verbindung drosseln also weiter stellen
will man so will auch beim wachstum von
gehirnzellen spielen endocannabinoide
eine rolle sie können zum beispiel den
zellen dabei helfen
vereinfacht gesagt die richtige
wachstums richtung zu finden und in
immunsystem kommen endocannabinoide als
botenstoffe zum einsatz sie beeinflussen
zum beispiel die beweglichkeit von
immunzellen oder die ausschüttungen
weiterer botenstoffe die
entzündungsfördernde sind das sind jetzt
nur ein paar beispiele für die vielen
funktionen von endocannabinoide wenn man
jetzt gift und sich dadurch cannabinoide
zu führt dann gretchen diese
cannabinoide er überall da rein wo
normalerweise unsere endocannabinoide
zum einsatz kommen das heißt an vielen
verschiedenen stellen im gehirn und im
körper während die cannabinoid
rezeptoren angesprochen
an manchen stellen kommt es zur über
aktivierung an anderer stelle kommt es
zu einer hemmung das ende cannabinoids
ihren gerät durcheinander und es kommt
zum rausch wie cannabis im körper wirkt
die bekannteste wirkung von cannabis ist
wahrscheinlich seine psychoaktive also
bewusstseinsverändernde wirkung die
hauptsächlich wenn auch nicht nur durch
thc ausgelöst wird aber da
endocannabinoide ja so viele
verschiedene funktionen im körper haben
beobachtet man auch beim kiffen viele
verschiedene wirkungen die scheinbar gar
nicht zusammenpassen die droge wirkt
entspannend führt aber auch zu lach
flash beeinträchtigt das
kurzzeitgedächtnis oder regt den appetit
an
[Musik]
dann hätten wir doch die
charakteristischen roten augen die
entstehen durch einen gesenkten
augeninnendruck wodurch die roten
äderchen stärker hervortreten und wir
haben auch noch cannabinoid rezeptoren
in unseren speicheldrüsen weswegen
kiffen auch einen trockenen mund macht
und versucht herauszufinden was der
deutsche begriff für cotton maut ist uns
würde pub maul und mund höchste
zurückgemeldet
kann hier im team leider nicht so gut
aus mit dem sling also wenn ihr es
besser wissen schreibt sie die
kommentare jedenfalls ökologisch wird
die ganze sache noch viel
unübersichtlicher wald ehc nicht nur die
cannabinoid rezeptoren anspricht sondern
auch noch viele andere rezeptoren unter
anderem und pyrit oder serotonin
rezeptoren und dann enthält er cannabis
auch noch über 100 verschiedene
cannabinoide von denen jedes auch anders
wirkt selbst kleine änderungen in der
chemische struktur könne zu einem großen
unterschied in der biologischen wirkung
führen darüber habe ich schon einmal in
diesem terrex video gesprochen wo es um
synthetische cannabinoide geht in
zukunft dass wir bei einem naturprodukt
wiener pflanze dann noch nicht einmal
die genaue zusammensetzung dieser
verschiedenen substanzen kennen was will
ich damit sagen
cannabis ist chemisch und
pharmakologisch betrachtet ziemlich
messi der begriff dirty drug wird
manchmal in der pharmakologie verwendet
für einen wirkstoff der zb an viele
verschiedene rezeptoren geht also eine
breite vielfältige wirkung hat was seine
wirkung unspezifischer macht und was
auch mit vielen nebenwirkungen einher
geht und das behalten wir jetzt mal im
hinterkopf aber wir machen erstmal
weiter mit dem suchtpotenzial von
cannabis bei drogensucht denken die
meisten wahrscheinlich an
heroinabhängigen der für den nächsten
schuss buchstäblich seine großmutter
verkaufen würde bzw als kind da die
dasselbe auch übergriffe aber heute
stellt man sich cannabis konsumenten her
nicht so vor jetzt ist ja für die
diagnose einer sucht oder einer substanz
abhängigkeit nicht das entscheidende
kriterium und man seine oma verkauft zu
den offiziellen kriterien zählen neben
körperlichen entzugserscheinungen wie
unruhe oder schlafstörungen
auch bestimmte verhaltensmuster zum
beispiel man konsumiert weiter obwohl
man merkt dass die substanz körperliche
oder geistige beschwerden verursacht
oder man nimmt ständig mehr als man
eigentlich wollte oder man bekommt
andere dinge die man eigentlich tun will
nicht mehr hin zum beispiel arbeit oder
zweiten seinen liebsten verbringen weil
man zu viel zeit mit konsum und
beschaffung verbringt hier gibt es zum
beispiel einen ganz hilfreichen online
selbst check für die eigene cannabis
abhängigkeit ist in der video
beschreibung verlinkt die gefahr
abhängig zu werden steigt natürlich mit
der häufigkeit des konsums in dieser
studie entwickelten von allen leuten die
einmal cannabis als droge ausprobiert
haben ca 9 prozent eine abhängigkeit
also definiert nach offiziellen
kriterien übrigens deutlich weniger als
bei alkohol 23 prozent oder nikotin 68
prozent in dieser studie beobachtete man
18 bis 30 jährige die regelmäßig
cannabis konsumierten aber zu
studienbeginn noch keine sucht zeigen
drei jahre später wurde bei 37 prozent
eine abhängigkeit diagnostiziert unterm
strich kann man so sagen cannabis macht
süchtig wenn auch weniger als die
legalen drogen alkohol oder nikotin aber
wie gefährlich ist es die möglichkeit
von cannabis cannabiskonsum ist oft mit
der natural stacy verbunden auf deutsch
naturalistischer viel schluss also den
glauben
viel glauben dass etwas natürliches wie
zum beispiel was pflanzliches
automatisch weniger gefährlich sei als
etwas chemisches also etwas
synthetisches das merkt man nicht nur im
vergleich mit anderen synthetischen
drogen sondern auch im vergleich mit
alkohol da glaubt man zb ethanol ist ja
ein molekül das in unserem körper gar
nichts verloren hat aber cannabinoide
diesen ja unseren körpereigenen
substanzen ähnlich das stimmt zwar sagt
aber noch nichts über die giftigkeit
einer substanz aus also dürfte ja sogar
ein leuchten
als eine substanz die ganz gezielt in
bereits bestehende biologische prozesse
eingreift im zweifelsfall sehr giftig
sein kann
cannabinoide wie thc können akut giftig
seien allerdings erst ab einer dosis die
man sich als mensch nicht auf einmal
rein kiffen könnte also wie immer die
dosis macht das gift in unserer quarks
sendung über drogen haben wir
todeszahlen verschiedener drogen
verglichen und 2017 gab es null cannabis
tote deswegen hört man oft das hat sich
ja noch nie jemand zu tode gekauft doch
da wir euch lieber vorsichtig hier sind
scheint in einem gewissen maß belastend
für das herz kreislauf system zu sein
vancouver ein herzinfarkt haben damit
einer erhöhten wahrscheinlichkeit in den
60 minuten nach dem kiffen
jetzt wird auch diskutiert ob das
vielleicht nur ein letzter auslöser ist
bei menschen die ohnehin schon herz grad
sind zum beispiel waldkirchen einfach
den puls erhöht oder ob doch noch mehr
dahinter steckt einige case reports
berichten von relativ jungen erwachsenen
kiefern ohne bedeutende risikofaktoren
die mit einem herzinfarkt ins
krankenhaus kam was man aber sagen kann
solche fälle scheinen sehr selten zu
sein muss man natürlich bedenken wenn
man cannabis klassischerweise durch
skizzen zu sich nimmt ist das ähnlich
wie zigarettenrauch auch schädlich für
die lunge thc und andere cannabinoide
wären zwar selbst nicht als
krebserregend eingestuft cannabis raucht
aber wohl ist naheliegend bzw plausibel
dass cannabis raucht ähnlich wie
zigarettenrauch lungenkrebs auslösen
kann nur es ist wissenschaftlich gar
nicht so einfach das so genau fest zu
machen weil viele käufer gleichzeitig
auch tabakrauchen und wenn es da jetzt
zum lungenkrebs kommt kann man im
nachhinein nicht mehr feststellen wie
viel davon jetzt allein auf den cannabis
raucht zurückzuführen ist aber zumindest
chronische bronchitis ist auch bei
kiefern zu sehen die nur gras ohne
tabakrauchen zusätzlich gibt es bei
kiefern ein leicht erhöhtes hohen
krebsrisiko was man bei tabak raucher
nicht sieht doch im vergleich mit
anderen drogen ist die tätigkeit
tatsächlich verschwindend gering allem
im vergleich mit unseren legalen drogen
und jetzt muss es ja nicht unbedingt
gleich tot sein was ist denn mit anderen
langfristigen schäden dieses bild ist
verteilten kiefers ist leider mehr als
nur ein klischee
man findet in der forschung immer wieder
hinweise dass kiffen langfristig die
kognitiven fähigkeiten also das
denkvermögen beeinträchtigt erstmal das
offensichtliche seien beeinträchtigt
verschiedene geistige fähigkeiten wie
zum beispiel arbeitsgedächtnis
lernfähigkeit oder aufmerksamkeit da
sieht man in verschiedenen labortests in
denen teilnehmer zum beispiel eine liste
von wörtern auswendig lernen sollen oder
zwei dinge gleichzeitig machen sollen
wie joystiq einen widerspenstigen cursor
in der mitte des bildschirms halten und
gleichzeitig bei einem bestimmten signal
immer den fuß von einem pedal nehmen
niemanden wundern dass man das
schlechter hinkriegt bewahren heißt aber
es sind genau diese geistigen
fähigkeiten bei denen kiefer durchweg
schlechte abschneiden
selbst wenn sie nüchtern sind eine
mögliche erklärung dafür ist dass sich
die cannabinoid rezeptoren auf einen
regelmäßigen hohen cannabiskonsum
einstellen indem sie weniger werden also
nach dem motto wir kriegen ja aber
reichlich dann brauchen wir nur noch
wenige rezeptoren aber diese rezeptoren
fehlen dann natürlich für ihre normalen
eigentlichen aufgaben des
endocannabinoide systems der mann mit
dem kiffen aufhört verbessern sich die
leistungen aber auch wieder viele
studien fanden nach einem monat keine
unterschiede mehr
die cannabinoid rezeptoren können sich
wahrscheinlich auch wieder nachjustieren
und wieder mehr werden solange man
regelmäßig kauft muss man davon ausgehen
dass die eigene geistige
leistungsfähigkeit permanent unterhalb
der eigentlich möglichkeiten ist dabei
sind nicht nur die stärksten kiefer
betroffen sondern auch diejenigen die
besonders früh damit angefangen haben
also in ihrer jugend unser gehirn ist
glastisch das bedeutet es verändert sich
ständig neue hirnzellen neue verknüpfen
wachsen ständig zum beispiel wenn wir
etwas lernen und diese hier in umbau
prozesse finden bei jugendlichen
deutlich stärker statt als bei
erwachsenen bei jugendlichen nimmt das
volumen der sogenannten grauen substanz
des gehirns erst zu und dann wieder ab
das heißt es gibt einen peak in der
gehirnentwicklung im jugendalter und wie
gesagt spielt das ende cannabinoid
system eine rolle bei der
gehirnentwicklung zum beispiel indem es
wachsenden gehirnzellen fortsetzen die
richtige richtung zeigt hat sie gehört
liebe jugendlichen freunde der sonne
passt auf eure gehirn auf sehr wichtiges
organ aber wenn cannabis aufs gehirn
wirkt kann man das nicht vielleicht auch
positiv nutzen cannabis als medizin im
internet gibt es etliche
erfahrungsberichte von menschen mit
bestimmten krankheiten die den cannabis
wunderbar geholfen hat nur hier ist das
problem wie mit allen einzelfall
berichten im netz ein paar denkt fallen
haben wir zum beispiel unseren placebo
video schon erklärt deswegen sollten wir
uns hier auf geprüfte wissenschaftliche
forschung beziehen und nicht auf
individuelle erfahrungsberichte da das
endocannabinoide system überall im
körper seine finger im spiel hat gibt es
auch viele verschiedene denkbare
medizinische einsatzbereiche für
cannabinoide die appetitanregende
wirkung genauso wie eine verminderung
des brechreiz es kann eine gewünschte
eigenschaft sein zum beispiel als
begleitung einer chemotherapie das nicht
berauschende cannabinoid keiner video
also cpd wird nachweist
bei bestimmten epilepsie formen und ist
seit ende letzten jahres für deren
behandlung zugelassen auch gegen
spastiken bei multipler sklerose
patienten ist ein cannabis extrakt bei
dem der gehalt von thc und cbd
kontrolliert wird für die anwendung
zugelassen unterschiedlichste weitere
anwendungen sind auch in der pipeline zb
zur behandlung des tourette syndroms
oder als krebstherapie
vor allem die antitumor eigenschaften
sprechen sich immer wieder rum und bei
manchen kommt dann macht der stillen
post an das diesen gegen krebs helfen
also dazu schon mal nein kippen ist
keine krebsvorsorge aber dass
endocannabinoide system spielt bei krebs
durchaus eine rolle zum beispiel gibt es
tumore die cannabinoid rezeptoren tragen
und in zell und tierversuchen konnten
einige cannabinoide tumore töten oder
verkleinern
entweder direkt oder als zusatz mittel
um die wirkung der chemotherapie zu
verstärken
doch bitte kein verfrühter jubel erstens
krebs ist leider vielfältig es gibt auch
krebs modelle bei denen die anti krebs
wirkung nicht durch eine aktivierung der
cannabinoid rezeptoren entsteht sondern
durch deren hemmung zweitens bei einigen
krebsarten zeigten cannabinoide eine
krebsfördernde wirkung oft wegen einer
hemmung des immunsystems aber vor allem
drittens keines dieser ergebnisse stammt
bisher aus klinischen studien mit
menschen
wir wissen also leider noch gar nicht ob
cannabinoide potenzial als medizin für
uns menschen haben und selbst wenn sind
noch viele fragen offen die zum beispiel
was es überhaupt die wirksame dosis und
können wir die überhaupt erreichen die
dosis macht das gift die dosis macht
auch das medikament und das generelle
problem von cannabinoiden als medizin
haben wir eigentlich schon am anfang
gesprochen sie sind dirty drugs man wird
in der medikamentenentwicklung versuchen
diese dirty druck sauberer zu kriegen
also zum beispiel indem man sich auf
bestimmte sauber isolierte cannabinoide
konzentriert die man dann in
kontrollierter menge zu einem präparat
weiterverarbeitet dass man dann auch
ordentlich testen kann und so weiter
oder man macht das ganze noch klima in
dem man ausgehend von cannabinoiden ganz
neue substanzen entwickelt die viel
spezifischer wirken als jetzt ein
isoliertes pflanzliches cannabinoid die
zum beispiel nur ein rezeptor
ansprechende stadt mehrere wer also
darauf hofft dass kiffen in dieser dirty
originalform standardmäßig als medizin
eingesetzt wird hat wahrscheinlich
schlecht haben nur so nebenbei sei sein
ist eine nebenwirkung also es gibt
natürlich auch menschen die nicht high
sein wollen allem nicht wenn sie krank
sind und ein medikament suchen das ihnen
einen möglichst normalen alltag
mitarbeiten und so weiter ermöglicht
ohnehin finde ich es wichtig dass man
cannabis als medizin und cannabis als
genussmittel trend also wer für eine
legalisierung ist weil er in seiner
freizeit kiffen möchte der sollte nicht
medizinisch argumentieren also man
sollte medizinische präparate niemals
zweckentfremden
es gibt ja auch noch andere argumente
gibt es ein recht auf rausch
wir können uns auf jeden fall darauf
einigen dass unsere aktuelle einteilung
in legale und illegale drogen nicht
logisch ist also zumindest keinen
wissenschaftlichen oder medizinischen
kriterien folgt aber das heißt ja nicht
automatisch dass man daraus folgern muss
cannabis zu legalisieren
man könnte ja auch alkohol und tabak
verbietet es bestimmt nicht die
beliebteste meinung aber eine rational
haltbare doch eines der größten probleme
mit illegalen drogen ist die
kriminalisierung und die
gesellschaftliche stigmatisierung in
diesem kontext noch mal ein verweis auf
die quarks drogen sendung und diese
düsseldorfer heroin klinik die süchtige
mit sauberem heroin versorgt weil
nicht die droge an sich sondern das
schmutzige straßen heroin und der
ausschluss aus der gesellschaft ist
woran die menschen kaputt gehen ich habe
auch mit marcel von texas tisch darüber
gesprochen
viele grüße an dieser stelle erst für
eine kontrollierte legalisierung und
eine art drogen aus weiß also dass strom
kontrolliert ausgegeben werden aber man
eine art führerschein machen muss für
einen verantwortungsvollen konsum den
man regelmäßig erneuern muss finde ich
grundsätzlich eine spannende idee aber
beim beispiel schmerzmittel die ärztlich
verschrieben werden und noch nicht
einmal als drogen stigmatisiert werden
merken doch sehr deutlich dass auch eine
kontrollierte ausgabe nicht automatisch
vor missbrauch oder sucht schützt das
alles nur als gedankenanstoß ich bin
sehr gespannt darauf in den kommentaren
zu lesen wie ihr das ganze sieht in der
endzeit verlinke ich euch noch die viele
räte quarks folge als ganze sendung und
ich war zu gast bei babbels und hat mit
david über viele schöne dinge wie zum
beispiel chemie gesprochen schaut vorbei
und hinterlasst wie immer gerne kekse
und zuletzt danke an alle die nach
unserem letzten video über das
elternsein bei der zwitter armen sprache
challenge mitgemacht haben bitte schön
[Musik]
wir haben was ist denn mit dir passiert
ein maibaum bist du rein riecht ganz und
voll mit prof